محمود الافندي الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي
اهلا بك استاذ محمود الافندي
نتوقف معك عند هذه الزياره التي يجريها
اردوغان رئيس التركي لاسوتشي وهذا اللقاء
المهم مع الرئيس الروسي في جوهره ربما
مساعي لاحياء اتفاقيات الحبوب
هل ربما من المنتظر ان نعود لهذه
الاتفاقيه
اول شيء اخي الكريم والمشاهدين طبعا تركيا
ترغب بعوده روسيا الى اتفاقيه الحبوب ولكن
انا اعتقد ان رئيس مهمه صعبه جدا اليوم
وخصوصا بعد انعدام الثقه فعليا بالنسبه
للحكومه الروسيه بشخصيه الرئيس اردو
التركي في اتفاقيه الحبوب وهو اتفاقيه
تبادل يعني اذا رجعنا شوي للتاريخ روسيا
تشك ان وزن الدفاع المسؤوله عن تفتيش
المواقع الفارغه عند الدخول المكرميه
للشحن من حبوب كانت تحمل الاسلحه وذخائر
بالاضافه ان الاتفاقيه تبادل الاسرع نعلم
جيدا ان الرئيس التركي اهدر الرئيسكي
مقاتلين ازوف التي تعتبرهم روسيا عصابه
فاشيه وكان هناك تعهد بالرئيس التركي ان
يطلقوا صلاحهم بعد انهاء العمليه
العسكريه لذلك انعدام الثقه سيكون يوم
مخير على الشيء لذلك الرئيس الروسي
بافتتاحه اللقاء عندما قال نعلم ان لديكم
يعني بعض المقترحات على اتفاق الحبوب نحن
مستعدين للسبع ولكن ان يكون هناك تحرك في
هذا الاتفاقيه نعلم جيدا ان لدى البارحه
قدم رساله للوزير خارج بما يسمى بعض
الشروط روسيا لا تريد اي نوع من انواع
الكلام فقط تريد الفعل يعني هي قالت شرط
واحد هناك اربع شروط او ارض الاتفاقيه هي
اتفاقيه بين الطرفين
ينفذ فقط بند واحد اخرى
على الاقل نفذوا البند المهم وهي اعاده
نظام السويتش المصرف الزراعه الروسي يمكن
ان روسي ان تعود يعني المشكله تكبر ليس
باقتراحات ولكن بالاضافه ان ما يحمله
اردوغان من اقتراحات هل سيصدقه الرئيس
ستكون وعود على
ولكن المشكله الان هل سيصدق الرئيس بوتين
في هذه المقترحات انا باعتقادي ان بالفعل
يعني هذه المباحثات بالنسبه لاتفاقيات
الحبوب سيكون شائكه جدا بالنسبه للطرف
التركي ولا اعتقد ان يكون هناك اي تقدم في
مباحثه اليوم استاذ محمود الافندي يعني
روسيا كانت ايضا قد تقدمت بمقترح
لاتفاقيه بديله هل يمكن ربما ان تكون هذه
الاتفاقيه البديله وما اكثر حظا من
سابقتها
هذا شيء واقعي لانه نعلم جيدا ان بالفعل
لما وقع الامين متحده اتفاقيه الحبوب كان
هناك مشكله انك كان يعلم جيدا ان الغرب
الذي يوافق
ولكن هو كسب الوقت وكسب سنه من اخراج
الحبوب من اوكرانيا الى دول العالم وهنا
دول العالم الاوروبي وليس العالم الثالث
للاسف ذهب فقط
الى دول افريقيا من اصل 33 مليون طن
الحبوب يعني لذلك روسيا عرضت الان اتفاقيه
مرنه اكثر يعني ما هي اتفاقيه الاكثر يعني
خطوه مقابل خطوه يعني تبدا مثلا تبدا
الطرف الغربي او يبدا خلي امم متحده تبدا
باعطاء ما يسمى شيء ملموس روسيا تعطي شيء
ملموس يعني كما يقول المثل في فيلم لوسي
مشهور يقول الصبح النقود والمساء الكراسي
يعني يجب ان يكون الخطوات مرينه وعمليه
وليست مكتوبه على الورق وت عهدات من الصعب
ان نكون يعني على سبيل المثال خلينا نكون
واقعيين هناك روسيا شرطت ان تفتح اوكرانيا
خط السماد من مدينه الياتي الى اوديسيا
الساحليه نعلم جيدا ان اوكر من حوالي
ثلاثه اشهر دمرت جزء من هذا الخط
تفجيره يعني المشكله تكمن ان هذه
الاتفاقيه كمكوناتها اصبحت من المستحيل ان
تكون عائشه على الوجود يمكن ايجاد اتفاقيه
هنا يمكن ان يكون هناك عدد التنازلات على
اساس بند مقابل بند وبعدها التوسيع يعني
نرى ما يمكن ان يكون في هذه الاتفاقيه
يمكن ان يطبق يطبق وبعد
لزياده الثقه بين الاطراف
المتشابكه يمكن ان نظهر باتفاقيه جديده
ولكن على مرحله زمنيه شكرا جزيلا لك من
موسكو محمود الافندي يا الاكاديمي
والمحلله السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك